so we have this uh video here and it's
from Project Veritas and I don't know
who this guy is it's uh it says busted
Pfizer CEO Albert borla relies on
aggressive security tactics to escape
Veritas journalists questions
do you know who this guy is I'm not
trying to be a dick to him I don't know
who he is what's his name Albert this no
this guy right here this journalist that
they have not yet so people started
telling me hey you know they they
removed James O'Keefe stripped him of
his authority put him on paid to leave
have explained almost nothing we had to
get leaked this this letter explaining
what people were claiming which sounds
outlandish and we've not gotten a
response from James then they put out a
video with some other dude we I don't
know James lolino project James we're
standing outside the Conrad Hotel in
Washington DC I just gotta say this you
know
isn't it doesn't it I tweeted this
morning that all the drama was part of a
plan because I was joking and it was
people took me seriously I said I was
like this Stephen Crowder on The Daily
wire and Tim to me in the quartering and
veritas and James O'Keefe you don't
think it's a coincidence do you phase
two begins soon and then people like
thought I was being serious I was just
pointing out like why is all of this
stuff happening right now and then of
course you know
later in the day you know I put out an
apology to Jeremy because
I I don't I don't think any of us have
any differences in the level of you know
what our what our real cultural and
ideological battles are in the culture
war and with politics like there's no
real reason for me to be you know
personally mad at German like that like
bickering like this like and I'll say
that for me like I've I have no reason
to even bring it up sure if he was
trying to put microchips in you and
track your movement then I'd say you
speak up or you know sterilize kids yeah
and things like that that's why I'm like
watching the Veritas stuff watching the
Crowder stuff and all of this happening
in the past couple of weeks and these
other stories about people get these
Republicans getting shot I'm kind of
like hey yo let's not like I I don't
know man look you y'all can tell me I'm
wrong about everything you can insult me
you can say uh Tim you you did bad I
will accept all of that I don't want
this to fall apart I will I will gladly
accept you can unsubscribe you can
unfollow you can not be a member anymore
I will I will gladly step back and say
the worst possible thing right now with
all of this going on is infighting and
I'm and and you know I'm sorry I don't
want this to happen I don't want things
to get worse this freaks me out so I'm
sure there's like multiple levels of
drama but um as far as the right having
this Civil War I'm actually extremely
glad it's happening I think Jose might
agree with me because it seems to be
separating the wheat from the chaff in a
lot of ways like this whole DeSantis
versus Trump stuff that's going on and
just seeing everyone turn on each other
uh seeing you know Matt Gates actually
stand up against
um uh McCarthy being elected speakers
stuff like that like it's uncomfortable
but it's actually kind of like forcing
the right to evolve if you know what I
mean it is but you know the reason I I
think Matt Gates is fantastic yes I said
this on the show the other day and he
brought it up that he's my favorite
member of Congress and I'm like well
look man he defended ilhan Omar someone
he shouldn't on a principled ground that
made sense and I respect that and then
he voted to have her removed on a
logical ground that made sense and I'm
like I get what he's doing he so you
know he said he gives speaker McCarthy
an a rating now they stood up they did
what they had to do they they they stood
up on principle when it came to swallow
well and shift being removed from their
committees he said that makes sense they
lied about intelligence I agree he said
removing ilhan Omar because she's had
things you don't like doesn't seem to
make sense it doesn't sit well with me
however ilhan Omar voted to remove
Marjorie Taylor green and gosar so
that's the standard she set so he's I'm
like that's actually logical that makes
sense I can respect that tremendously so
when looking at the the McCarthy stuff
that I'm in favor of you know them
standing up to the establishment saying
we get these concessions but I don't see
any net gain in all of us at the base
level fighting with each other
at all I I don't I don't see
any of us succeeding if all all of a
sudden the exact same time we all find
reason to have beef with each other you
know what I mean it helps you identify
good faith actors in my opinion yeah
that's that's really yeah I know it
splits things up and it to me I see I
see like crisises and stuff like it's
almost inevitable I think you're almost
better to make the best of it and what
this was was this was a you're able to
identify things from here you're able to
see who your in group was who your
outgroup was uh who's willing to act in
good faith who's not I mean that's not
safe they're perfect actors on the
inside but you can tell uh I mean
throughout all this drama there's been
so many crazy claims and it allows you
to be like yeah I probably won't work
with that person probably not gonna
interact with them et cetera et cetera
you don't have to cause a problem over
it but it allows you to be able to see
the battlefield what's going on et
cetera et cetera yeah this is this is
the the challenge that I basically see
with all of this stuff is you know Vera
this should not be happening in veritas
at all if they've got problems with
James O'Keefe they should not have
handled this way this is this is
horrible mismanagement made me take
stock of what I was doing and I'm like I
shouldn't be so reckless and Brash and
and arrogant at the same because like I
see see that and then it reflects on me
what am I doing this is a this is a bad
way to handle it especially if we're
trying to be strategic and tactful so
that we can focus on issues like I don't
know people smuggling eggs over the
Mexican border because the prices are so
insane like things we actually have to
accomplish because we're concerned that
they're letting non-citizens vote in
Washington DC or New York or are
outright as many people are pointing out
censorship due to people filing false
privacy claims or legal challenges
exploiting the system to gain some kind
of political power and I can respect
that so at that point I'm just like
yeah we that I I'm genuinely freaked out
not to mention you know what really does
it is like we can have drama and
whatever and I'm kind of like whatever
and then I see these two Republicans in
Jersey get killed and I'm kind of like
okay guys let's let's get serious we're
you know we're let's let's get serious
yeah we're lucky to be able to
experience drama in a conversational way
that's we're very privileged in this
Society be able to Hash it out with
words before it would ever come to
anything other than that we can we can
you know I put it this way I might I
meant you you mentioned it allows you to
see who you might not want to work with
and who you want to work with we can see
the camps right the audience sizes here
and a different audience here and
there's some overlap and some people get
mad this way and some people get mad
that way and I'm just like but why are
we mad at each other I should I
shouldn't be be doing that because the
people over there are doing really
messed up stuff they're lying to the
American people they're spreading false
intelligence they're putting ankle
weights on a president who gave us the
best economic numbers in a generation
and then resulted in us getting a Joe
Biden who gives us some of the worst and
I'm kind of like yeah I I think we've
gotta we've got to make sure we're
focused on that stuff you know I oh I
was thinking well you go for it you
triggered him with the uh Trump
economics oh yeah well I mean I do have
to address that I mean we were
definitely when Trump ran for president
in 2016 he even said we're living in a
bubble it's gonna pop this isn't
actually a good economy until he was
President then suddenly it was the
greatest economy in the world until it
crashed when he's gone you know I don't
think that has much to do with uh Trump
or Biden or Obama it's more about the
Federal Reserve policies we had over
that time but that aside I think it's
important I think the fox in the hen or
the the wolf in sheep's clothing is more
dangerous than the fox in the hen house
so like an obvious enemy me is less of a
threat because it's easy to point out
it's easy to say this person is
dangerous and they're against what we
stand for when you have somebody I would
say like Trump who virtue signals on a
lot of important issues but then nine
times out of ten when it comes down to
it he goes along with whatever the
establishment wants I think that's more
dangerous I mean under Biden you've had
legitimate right-wing opposition to what
he's been doing if Trump were still
president right now I don't think you'd
have nearly the amount of solidified
opposition to what's going on in the
white house I mean because we saw that
in 2020. when you look at wage wages and
inflation right when Joe Biden gets put
right when Joe Biden gets inaugurated
then right after he enacts a plethora of
executive orders you start to see a
dramatic shift in wages starting to go
down sure and inflation's starting to go
up so you think that's a coincidence no
I don't think it's coincidence I mean
the cares Act was the largest spending
bill in U.S history signed by Donald
Trump in March of 2020 the covid Relief
act of 2020 was the second largest
spending Bill signed into law by
President Trump in December of 2020 and
so sure Biden's energy policy does
nothing to help it definitely makes it
worse but to act like printing trillions
and trillions of dollars out of midair
when we had a Republican president and
locking the economy down which wasn't
his fault I'm not blaming him I mean
Democrat Governors sure well Republican
Governors too both but to act like that
wouldn't have you know effects
regardless of whether or not he gets
elected like even if Donald Trump got
reelected and was still president you
would have 95 of this inflation the
inflation is increasing the money supply
I mean I I agree to the extent that the
spending was bad but also you take a
look at the for one like obviously the
energy policy of of Joe Biden but you
take a look at a whole bunch of other
things I mean they're they're they're
enacting policy based on ideological
ends Joe Biden literally said he was
going to end fossil fuels before the
pandemic the the economy was the best
numbers of Our Lives obviously not
during the pandemic so if you get a
knee-jerk reaction that results in Mass
spending and panic but you have a
tendency among democrats for Harsh and
total lockdown you get a Joe Biden who
starts speaking about the lockdowns only
to Blue States and not red States and
then you know previous to this you had
some red States saying no and opening
back up you get a Joe Biden that comes
into office and acts a bunch of uh
policies you get the inflation reduction
act quote unquote and then you watch in
real time as inflation continually gets
worse stagnates at extremely high levels
or continues to get worse yeah I think
if Donald Trump was President we
probably have better academic policy I
think things would probably be recovered
well you got a DeSantis because you had
Biden I don't think he would have had a
DeSantis under Trump DeSantis and I've
got lots of issues with DeSantis but
when he was opposing the coveted regime
in Florida where Jose is living
um I think a lot of that was because
there was political will to have a
dissenter to the you know the official
narrative that Joe Biden was putting out
with Donald Trump I think that would
have been a lot less likely I think if
you have a central authority figure that
people can hate and they can actually
oppose not just like in a virtue
signaling way and not just in an
emotional way but actually come out
against it that's how you get an action
I think a good example of what breed's
getting at is just a quick little thing
the majority of gun control gets pushed
through under Republican presidents and
the reason why is because exactly what
he's saying when you have someone like
abide in an office you actually get a
legitimate Republican pushback whereas
you have somebody like a a conservative
in office you know they're able to push
through these huge bills or these things
would typically be not conservative
because like no one wants to rock the
boat I just want to clarify that if I
had to compare Joe Biden with Donald
Trump I do prefer Donald Trump's
policies to Joe Biden I'm just talking
your reactionary people you're coming at
it from a libertarian's perspective sure
so the the underlying statement that
you're making is Donald Trump is not a
Libertarian which I don't think he's not
even a republican well I mean he's he's
a he's a progressive Republican probably
along he's a 90s Democrat yeah that's
and that's fair and that's fine but
if you're arguing that Donald Trump is
not libertarian enough for you that's a
legitimate argument because Donald Trump
wasn't trying to be libertarian well
it's fair to say that Donald Trump isn't
libertarian enough for libertarian
people and and I I mean most your
criticisms I agree because I think you
know I I prefer a smaller government but
holding Donald Trump to the libertarian
standard and saying well he's not a
Libertarian when everybody that's a
Donald Trump support is going to go duh
we don't care I don't think that's you
know what I mean that's not my argument
my partner play between the different
parties my argument is actually to
achieve libertarian policies is easier
on a state level under Joe Biden than it
would be under Donald Trump because it's
easier to Rally opposition to Joe Biden
like stuff that's happened in Florida
stuff that's happened in New Hampshire
it's very easy because it's easy to rile
up your right-wing neighbor and say do
you want Joe Biden to be able to have
Federal jurisdiction over what happens
in New Hampshire and they'll say hell no
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time